okay so the johnny depp and amberhead
trial is now into its final week and we
should shortly be getting a verdict
since our last video on the
cross-examination we've had several of
amber's witnesses come forward and
testify to what they say happen between
the pair we've also had a number of
high-level hollywood executives arguing
over whether amber's career was affected
or not by this entire thing as always
we're going to be breaking down what was
said and going over the main points of
each day while stores are playing
relevant video clips of the highlights
now amber's side was always going to be
bad for johnny depp but i'm still not
sure whether she's really done enough to
prove things in her favor many people
keep forgetting that this is a
defamation case and that johnny is
basically trying to show that his career
livelihood and reputation were affected
by the op-ed which his agent hollywood
executives and many witnesses have
backed up though there's a lot of really
dark things being said in the trial that
is ultimately what the decision will be
over and herd's team are firstly trying
to justify that the op-ed was truthful
whilst also saying that it wasn't about
johnny heard is denied at several points
the op-ed was about him but she's also
using the strategy of accusing him of
doing what was in it in order to
basically cover the most ground against
depp he is currently suing amber for 50
million dollars and on the opposite side
of this amber is countersuing for 100
million stating that she has lost that
amount of potential earnings due to
everything surrounding their
relationship and whether you think
that's an accurate figure to put next to
her career is another point entirely but
yesterday johnny's team put forward the
notion that her counterclaim should be
rejected and that she should in fact be
suing adam waldman he stated that her
entire story was fabricated in a daily
mail interview which apparently opened
the floodgates of public opinion turning
against her the church rejected this
idea and at the moment everything still
stands in place you might remember that
a couple of weeks ago amber's team
attempted to have johnny's case thrown
out as well and i think that both legal
sides were probably just exhausting the
options they had in order to see if they
could get a win in some way or another
when i last reported on this story eloya
actually reached out to me and said it's
a standard procedure for this to happen
and that 99.9 of these kinds of actions
are rejected by the judge now with
amber's counterclaim comes the idea that
she basically had a bright career ahead
of her that was snuffed out you might
have seen reports detailing how hood's
role in aquaman 2 was massively cut down
and we even got some major spoilers on
the movie this week without a bloody
spoiler warning we also have the dc film
president talk about why they were
contemplating recasting her anyway which
i'll play after this first witness so
you can kind of see one statement and
then the other now catherine arnold was
brought forth as an amber witness to
talk about this and the apparent
hollywood expert detailed dep's career
decline and also her opinion on why
heard was about to be the next big thing
the first clip i'm going to play
revolves around why she thinks depp's
career went downhill for reasons other
than the op-ed and then we'll go into
why she thinks amber had lost out on 50
million dollars based on your analysis
what has caused mr depp's career
downturn
and i realize you've said a number of
those so is there anything else sure uh
well we talked about the erratic
behavior the tardiness the drugs and
alcohol abuse and
the lawsuits have had a really big
impact not just this lawsuit but
previous lawsuits that mr depp has been
involved with because there's a lot of
publicity around anything that he does
and
every time he has filed a lawsuit it is
brought to light various issues with
respect to whatever that lawsuit was
about whether it was about
you know erratic behavior or domestic
abuse
or drugs and alcohol
and even spending habits so every time a
lawsuit has been filed
the press and the publicity has just
been charged up and brought everything
back to light and it's
it's been an unfortunate problem for for
on that level for the industry to
continue to work with him even though
all this is out in the in the public
okay so catherine basically talking
there about how it was johnny taking
people to court that caused his career
to drop which i don't really agree with
and in all honesty i think the op-ed and
photos that amber put out made it
difficult to hire him again this is
something hollywood executive richard
marks discussed and he went over how
there was basically a no tolerance
policy on any accusations after the
metoo movement which we did detail in
our other videos i'm going to play two
more clips of catherine's statement and
then we'll go over richard marx's
assessment of it and why he thinks this
is completely up the mark did amber have
a contract for aquaman one
yes
how much was she paid for aquaman one
aquaman one she was paid two million
dollars okay and did that same contract
uh provide for if she was in aquaman two
i'm sorry i apologize aquaman won i
believe she got one million dollars
aquaman two she was supposed to get two
million dollars i apologize the numbers
there were a lot of numbers in that one
contract so aquaman won it was one
million all command two is gonna be two
million
all right now based on your experience
and knowledge in the industry
how much would amber hurt have been able
to negotiate uh her contract but for the
deb waldman statements
for aquaman too i'm asking right well as
you can see from mr mimo's contract that
went up exponentially up to 15 million
dollars
misheard i don't know if she would have
gotten 15 million dollars for the movie
but she certainly could have increased
it by one or two million dollars or even
doubled it so if it was two it could
have been four
or even five or six depending on the
enthusiasm if had just rolled from
aquaman juan to aquaman two without any
of this
negativity that was created by the
walmart the dead woman statements what
happened with these other actors after
they had their
unrelated to q scores right right okay
sorry so all those actors careers the
ones i mentioned they all either were a
steady rise or even a meteoric rise in
in terms of where their career went
after their stars born moment then they
got some other good films and maybe they
got another film that performed
extremely well so it was a range but
they all were on an upward trajectory
without a doubt
and what does this mean for amber
with a reason i mean the way that the
the kind of industry works is usually
unless there is an uh forced major or
some really negative event
her career should have followed that
same upward swing and in about the same
time frame it give or take six months to
a year but you it would be very
reasonable to
to believe that her career would have
been on an upward trajectory
within the range
of those other actors so over the course
of five years it's very reasonable to
consider that she would have been in at
least one film a year
at a minimum of four million dollars
because that's
what her president would have been had
she renegotiated and it's important to
note that in her inner justice league
contract
had their if there is a aquaman
three
her price is set at four million dollars
so it's very reasonable to assume
and to believe
that
if she did a film a year
for five years at a minimum of four
million a year without any negotiation
which probably would have happened but
let's just say that baseline that would
be another 20 million dollars over that
time frame so combining all of these
opinions and calculations that you've
had what if any range are the losses you
are estimating for amber heard but for
the deb waldman statements
right so again it's really important
that i looked at and hopefully you
understand this that it's over time
right so let's just say a minimum of
five years that we're going to talk
about these losses and it could be more
but at minimum if you look at the
film
the television
and the endorsement contracts
it's very likely that ms heard should
have earned between 45 and 50 million
dollars over that time period so
catherine basically outlining there why
she thinks amber would have got that
much money however she also slipped up
quite a lot and showed that she probably
wasn't as clued in as she thought she
was catherine didn't know robert
pattinson was the current batman and she
also failed to take into account the
fact that warner brothers don't always
up contracts which was seen in fantastic
beasts there's also actors who don't
necessarily get brought across into
sequels like terence howard with iron
man and once we get into walter hamada's
statement it will show why her return
wasn't necessarily a guarantee as i
wasn't looking to give her the same
career as jace mamoa i took her numbers
that her agents had actually negotiated
and worked from there
when you say you weren't
trying to give her the same career as
jason mamawa
the
the tv
program that she most recently did the
stand
she made 200 000 an episode that's what
you testified to correct
and in your damage analysis
you give her a million dollars an
episode had the waldman statements not
occurred and you do it only because
you believe mr momoa has gotten that in
in in something that he's in right so
you are giving her the same career as
jason mama well again with someone like
uh
ms hurd who was in a blockbuster film
with the team at william morris in my
discussions with william morris that's
what they were looking to negotiate for
her on other projects so i got some of
that information from her man so the
formula and logic kind of falls down
there under scrutiny and this was
further hammered home by richard marx
for some context to this hood was
compared to the big a-listers that start
off this question i have got bits out of
this as there's several objections from
amber's side but the questions just get
answered anyway so i'm saving you three
minutes of them just arguing that mark
shouldn't be allowed to answer that
before it's eventually overruled
do you understand that ms arnold
compares ms heard's career trajectory
with that of other actors including
jason momoa gal gadot zendaya anada
armis and chris pine
i heard that and what's your opinion of
those actors as comparables from his
heart
again
they are not comparable
jason momoa was aquaman
chris pine was captain kirk
gal gadot was wonder woman
zendaya has been working
on disney channel since she was 13
she's in all the spider-man movies she
goes by one name
anna de armas
you know when she was in
a movie
that they call
you know her breakout
it was as a a nude poster she's been an
ensemble piece knives out these are not
comparables
now
miss arnold stuck to jason momoa who's
the most
non-comparable because of his history
and his career
but she didn't give us the advantage of
telling us what his contracts were
what he renegotiated to what he earned
she didn't give us any of those building
blocks she just created she set him up
as a comparable
and then said what
miss heard should earn but she never
gave us the salary of jason momoa or the
other comparables and
if she built like this house of cards on
nothing
uh you know she showed us the the
with her words the beautiful clothing
that the emperor was wearing but but we
could see if you
know the business yeah objection you're
on earth that he wants to be honest you
were just speaking about mr mamoa as a
comparable are you aware that
ms arnold compares miss her to
mr mamoa as an actor with equivalent
franchise experience who was able to
renegotiate his salary for significant
increases in bonus yes what's your
response to that opinion
again he didn't have comparable
franchise experience to to misheard
he was
conan the barbarian he played aquaman in
a movie that amber heard was not in
he played aquaman
not a supporting character like mira
it's just not comparable
and
you can say the words
but but i saw nothing for miss arnold to
back it up
something to build on which
if she was a negotiator in the trench
the the studio negotiator would say okay
so show us
where's the cops let's talk numbers
because ultimately that's what we have
to get to
not just because you say it so we just
don't believe you you've got to show us
so yeah pretty much shut down what
arnold was saying and it kind of
derailed the 50 million valuation marx
also brought up the fact that salaries
are factored into the budget of a movie
as well so for example if aquaman 5 is
gonna cost 200 million dollars if jason
momoa at that point is getting a salary
of 40 million then they're not also
going to have 20 million spare to give
to amber because the movie isn't going
to have that budget i'm not going to
spoil aquaman 2 even though that's
that's probably on brand for me but
there were major plot points given on
the movie during the testimonies and
mira basically is gonna show up at the
start be taken out of the plot for the
majority of it and then show up at the
end her role is really diminished so
these valuations go out the window quite
a bit now you could blame this all in
the drama going on but walter hamada
gave a testimony that shut down the idea
that she was as sought after as arnold
believed marta goes over why they were
actually talking about recasting mira
after the first movie because herd and
mamoa didn't have any chemistry he also
goes over her contract with studio and
the workings of dc in general i'm gonna
cut between the two pieces and also
shout asthma and gold for his reaction
during this first moment at any point in
time from the beginning of history to
today
did warner brothers
re-hire
ms heard
for aquaman 2
no because we just picked up her option
did miss heard receive a pay increase
for aquaman feud
no was her role ever reduced for any
reason
um no i mean again from the early
stages of the development of this all
right
the movie was built around
the character damn arthur and the
character form
arthur being jason momoan or from being
patrick wilson
um so they were always the two
co-leads of the movie wealth for
compensation
for aquaman two
affected in any way by anything said by
johnny depp
no
was there any delay
in warner brothers exercising the option
to cast
misheard and aquaman few
yes there was uh there were
conversations about potentially
recasting
was the producer
what if any creative concerns
did warner brothers have
about asking
amber heard as mira and aquaman too good
question it was the concerns that were
brought up uh at the rap of the first
movie production first movie which is
the issue of chemistry did the two epic
chemistry um you know i think
editorially they were able to make that
relationship work in the first movie but
there was a concern that it took a lot
of effort to get there
and would we be better off
recasting finding someone who had better
more natural chemistry with piece of moa
and move forward
right this is the guy the warner
brothers that runs
did you speak it all with jason momoa
in preparation for your
deposition today
no
have you ever spoken with jason mamoa
about any issues relating to chemistry
between he and amber
um yes
when did you speak with jason momoa
about chemistry issues between he and
pembroke
that would have been in that same time
period where we were
prior to green light of the movie
now
you were asked some questions about
scripts
uh
did you review any of the drafts of the
script for aquaman ii
yes
when
i
part of my role
the scripts as they come in
when was the first script for aquaman
two oh boy
i could not tell you probably in 2018
the latter part of 2018 would be my
guess
and
how many versions of the script had been
written by
the beginning of 2021
for aquaman 2
dollar there were probably
half dozen graphs of the script all
right what if anything did rob cowan say
to you about chemistry what's
specifically about the chemistry between
amber heard and jason malmoa
just the the fact that they didn't
really have a lot of chemistry together
um you know the the reality is
it's not uncommon on movies for for two
leads to not have chemistry and that
it's sort of movie magic and editorial
the ability to sort of put performances
together and with the magic of you know
a great score and and how you put the
pieces together you can you can
fabricate sort of that chemistry um and
so i think in in at the end of the day i
think if you watch the movie they look
like they had great chemistry but i just
know that through the course of the
post-production that it took a lot of
effort to get there sometimes you don't
sometimes it's very easy you just put
the you know characters on screen
together and they work and sometimes
it's harder and more specifically did
you play any role
in the determination
to communicate to amber's
representatives that warner brothers was
considering not exercising her option
um
yeah probably in the sense of we had the
conversations and i believe if i recall
we had uh
that's where peter safran
offered to reach out to the agent uh and
express which direction we were leaning
so yeah the defamation claim i heard
seems to be unfounded when the president
of dc films was saying there was talks
of recasting her and that she had a
reduced role in the second film which is
basically going to be a brother comedy
team-up there's a lot of conspiracy
theories going around about it at the
moment saying that he's lying to save
face and that they reduced her role
because of the trial but remember this
is under oath now speaking of being
under oath there's also talk of her
being investigated for perjury after
telling the uk high court that she gave
her divorce settlement to charity during
the liable case with her son and mistake
that she had donated the full amount
however we now know that this was just
pledged and that it hasn't been paid
across going to be interesting to see
how this develops and herd's witnesses
appear through video deposition
throughout the week there's not really
that many highlights and most tend to
corroborate the same stories that they
witness bruising on amber and also hid
arguments between the pair whitney
amber's sister was also brought into
this and she discussed the australia
incident i've had numerous issues with
youtube posting clips about that
specific thing so i think the best thing
to do is just talk about it rather than
playing the testimony whitney said that
johnny struck amber and that he was
verbally abusive to her when he was
intoxicated this did counter the
security guard's testimony who said that
only amber was the one that attacked so
it's very much going to come down to the
jury to decide what they believe it's
been argued that because the security
guard travis was employed by debt that
he's buys but you could also say that
because whitney is amber's sister that
she is too now jennifer howell also
ended up dropping quite a big bombshell
in chord and she actually went over
whitney's statement turns out that she'd
emailed her and asked her to come clean
about her sister she testified under
oath that amber had lied about the
entire thing and the donations and that
she wasn't doing this to side with
johnny just to free whitney from her
sister's control this is something that
has often been levied against her and to
have this come out was a major blow to
her side why did you send this email and
letter to mrs enriquez
because i've struggled very much with
what to do in a situation that
i love someone who i know is doing
something very wrong and i know that
they're doing it because
they're trying to protect their sister
and
i'm trying to protect her and i'm just
trying to get her to wake up and do the
right thing which is tell the truth
that's the only thing that can help
everybody involved in this case
the whole thing was pretty damning and
to hear it from someone who's meant to
be quite impartial was a massive blow
for amber's team now kate moss is also
someone that is now a major player in
all of this if you cast your mind back
to amber's testimony then you might
recall that she brought up kate moss and
discussed the incident in which she'd
heard that she'd been pushed down the
stairs this was a big moment in which
depp's team celebrated and it massively
rocked the case moss was originally not
allowed to be a witness because she was
judged as being irrelevant to the entire
thing however because amber brought her
up during her testimony this allowed
depp's team to call her to the stand
amber initially used kate moss as a way
to show he had been abusive to other
partners however today most tore this
open and denied all of these rumors
afternoon
your time
uh my name is ben chu from the firm of
brown rudnick
would you please state your full name
for the record
kate smuss miss moss where do you reside
london england
from where are you testifying today miss
moss
i'm gloucestershire england
miss moss do you know johnny depp
yes i do
how do you know mr depp
i had a relationship with him
uh did there come a time when you and mr
depp had a romantic relationship
yes
for how long ms moss were you and mr
depp a romantic couple
from 1993
to
1994 to 1998.
miss moss did there come a time when you
uh while you and mr depp were a couple
that the two of you took a vacation
together
to the golden eye resort in jamaica
yes
what if anything happened when you were
in jamaica with mr depp
i um
we were leaving the room
and johnny left the room before i did
and there had been a rainstorm
and
as i left the room i slid down the
stairs
and i hurt my back
how did you
i apologize miss miles please continue
and i screamed because i was in
because i didn't know what happened to
me and i was in pain and um
he came
running back to help me
and carried me to my room and
got me medical attention
did mr depp push you in any way down the
stairs
no
during the course of your relationship
did he ever push you down any stairs
no he never pushed me kicked me
or
threw me down any stairs
miss moss have you ever before today
testified in any kind of court
proceeding no i have never
why did you decide to testify today
objection your honor
all right let's be on the scope of what
we just talked about
all right i'll sustain the objection
thank you miss moth uh we have nothing
further at this time we greatly
appreciate your taking the time
to testify any cross-examination no your
honor all right you're free to go thank
you ms boss thank you very much
all right your next witness it was
crushing to hurt's testimony and acted
as a great character witness to johnny
which coupled with the other witness
statements really helped his case kate
moss is something that amber tried to
weaponize to make johnny look bad but it
backfired on her massively and will
likely make people wonder what else
she's making up now we also had dr david
spiegel who diagnosed deaf as a
narcissist without having ever met him
and only from hearing second hand
accounts his company said that you
shouldn't do this and then he did it
which was brought up in the
cross-examination he got really
argumentative and had to be asked by the
judge to calm down which made him come
across as a really bad witness the
internet's pretty much been going wild
calling him doc brown from back to the
future and uh
no comment on if that's a fair
comparison now i've cut this down a fair
bit because they just go over stuff
about ethics of his testimony for about
eight minutes and it just goes in
circles so i've saved you that one as
well
the rule in fact contemplates
that issue doesn't it sir
again i'm just telling you the answer to
the question when you're reading me
those statements
i'm telling you the response by the
other side who was publishes also
is that
if that was the case there could be no
expert witness testimony in the
courtroom
psychiatrists are ethically prohibited
from evaluating individuals without
permit without permission
or
other authorization
such as a court order that's the rule
right
again if you're reading that then i have
to believe you're not misrepresenting it
and i would come back to you again
then
this whole thing on effort we might as
well get rid of all the expert witnesses
we've had throughout all of time for
court proceedings because that you're
saying is unless a court orders it and
that's what you just said or the ap said
then therefore expert witnesses cannot
do an evaluation based on an observation
of the medical records insurance
companies cannot do evaluations solely
based on medical records with our
doctors rendering professional opinions
so at the end of the day you are
essentially saying that unless someone
has directly evaluated it there this
whole medical system we have this whole
legal system we have is null and void
i'm not saying no yes you are sir i know
you are give me a give me a second and
i'll give you more than a second
what what i'm
saying and what i am reading to you
is a rule
by your organization
that
takes into account
that there could be court orders that
would permit the the exact kind of
evaluation that you say i'm eliminating
and i think we're going in circles
because i think i just said that means
expert witness testimony
would not be allowed and the branch of
forensic psychiatry would be especially
hindered and we know the branch of
forensic high does not prohibit that so
i am a member of the apa that doesn't
necessarily mean every single thing they
put in there everybody has to
uncategorically agree with because
clearly that's not the case
let's start with the easy question then
maybe we can i was pretty easy go ahead
all right doctor you're going to have to
just answer the questions okay sorry
about that
getting into it you you need to just
answer the question
you are not rendering any diagnosis
whatsoever of mr depp
today or ever
i probably would say to you that
certainly i would not say narcissistic
personality traits
certainly from what i have read an
intimate partner violence is not a
diagnosis so the answer is no for that
narcissistic personality trace is not a
diagnosis the answer is no but if you
want to tell me that substance use
disorder
is a psychiatric diagnosis
the answer is
yes and i but that wasn't an issue was
it whether mr mr depp used substances
i mean you said you've gone through the
record that that wasn't really an issue
at this trial he's said it from day one
i should say he's already admitted to
the diagnosis he's already admitted to
the use of the substances well again
there's different admitting to substance
use and substance use disorder let's go
back to uh what you just said about
narcissistic personality traits yes
narcissistic personality disorder
is a dsm-5
diagnosis correct correct
diagnosis
diagnostic personality and you haven't
testified that mr depp has
um
narcissistic personality disorder have
you
i would surely if i didn't i'm certainly
thinking that but at least i'm going to
say he has traits which are
characteristics of provisional diagnosis
of it's a provisional diagnosis probably
a narcissistic person but yeah i mean i
do believe that
now from here he also talked about dep's
behavior on set from what he'd been told
there's been testimony around the
around that picture that
mr depp fell asleep with
ice cream in his hand that's not
vomitous right i i was told it was
vomitous okay
um
you talked about the fact that mr depp
uh
indicates that from time to time
he uses an earpiece
i was yeah i mean i i read that yes okay
um
did you
read the testimony of mr wyatt who told
you what was being pumped into that
earpiece yeah i mean if i if i remember
right i mean it was i think it was lines
right
no it was music
it was music not inclined yeah okay so
if
if mr depp was listening to music
rather than being fed his lines
does that change your opinion as to his
cognitive function
if he was never fed his lines through
the earpiece which i
know he was
but read he was and that may have been
that example mr wyatt may have said that
it was music i guess the question is
were you having the music
during the during the actual talking of
your line is that what you're saying to
me
well you know if if you can do two
things at once that's a pretty high
cognitive function isn't it sir you know
it's very good point actually divided
attention is something humans have a lot
of trouble in so for instance we have
trouble driving and putting on the you
know using our uh cell phones and direct
so divided attention humans actually are
not very good at i'll put that out there
but mr in general not just mr depp and
jeff but but mr depp is pretty good at
acting you you you acknowledge that
early on
absolutely better than me so i know that
because you don't act in fact you don't
know about acting
you're right i have no idea about that
and you don't know
how prevalent the use of ear pieces are
in acting
again i
i know nothing about acting
irrespective of the fact you know
nothing about acting you've testified
that mr depp's use of an earpiece is
somehow a cognitive deficit
so if i was giving a lecture and i was
fed my lines i would think there's a
cognitive deficit so i'm and maybe i'm
wrong i said maybe i could be wrong baby
hollywood stars get
lines fed to them through ear pieces all
the time and i i don't know
i that could be it sounded to me to be
unusual if you're doing a movie and you
don't know the lines but like you said
i'm just judging you know what i do with
lectures and that would never happen
if you gave lectures you wouldn't use an
earpiece but you're not going to tell
anybody how to act
i'm sorry what was the question
i said if you gave lectures you wouldn't
use an earpiece but you're not telling
anybody how to act right i would not use
an earpiece during lectures right but i
again i don't know what the standard for
care of how standard is hollywood is for
that i have no idea
your use
your testimony about the use of an
earpiece
as
maybe you were wrong
you're comfortable with the fact that
you may have made a mistake there
no because i think in the basis of what
i've read about it i'm comfortable that
i i don't believe that
actors are routinely given their entire
script through earpieces i find that
hard to believe yeah but but not one
word of evidence that this ever happened
i hear i guess what i said i just said i
find it hard to believe i didn't say it
i said i find it hard to believe that's
all i said oh yeah but what you found
hard to believe sir was that every
every line of the script was was pumped
through an earpiece where did you ever
get the idea that ever that occurred
that's what i have been that's what i
read and the court review the court
evidence that's where i got it
and um
you know whether marlon brando used an
earpiece
whether isn't he dead
yeah so the answer is no he does not use
one now oh no i i i used the past tense
oh i'm sorry uh
again i know nothing i will concede to
you i know nothing about acting
i will concede to you 100
if that is the standard and people are
done that's acting then i apologize and
that was wrong on my part
if that's the standard i'm wrong i don't
know
okay
let's go with that no further questions
all right how long so yeah kind of
you know i am trying to stay as unbiased
as possible but from my point of view
these witnesses didn't really help the
case that much and at that point i was
thinking they did more damage than good
kind of got me thinking is this the best
that amber's team has as there were so
many of her so-called experts that
didn't really hold up under scrutiny now
johnny did have bad days and good days
but i don't think that was really enough
given to make me think that he hadn't
lost out on roles because of the op-ed
which i do personally believe was about
him even with the denials from her side
whether they can fully prove it is
another matter but going beyond a
reasonable doubt i think that most
people would agree that it did cost him
jobs and after hearing the cross this
week i'm not sure if amber actually lost
that on things because of the reports
about her i have to keep telling people
this is a defamation case and though the
more extreme things coming out about it
grab the headlines at the crux of it
that is what the jury have to decide and
to me johnny has come out looking a lot
better than amber has and i think his
side have argued the points way better
than hers have could be wrong but of
course let me know below what you think
after hearing the highlights this trial
is drawing to a close and i will try and
do a follow up on it at some point so
make sure you stay locked to the channel
on screen now we have a link to our
other videos so definitely go and check
them out right after this without the
way thanks for sitting through this one
take care peace